when you're trying to solve a triangle
sometimes what they'll give you is three
pieces of the triangle they want you to
solve for all six so the three other
missing pieces
the only issue though here is is that
the way this triangle is drawn right now
it's not what they call rigid so they're
giving us this angle and they're giving
us the side and they're giving us the
side across from this angle but there's
a potential for one triangle two
triangles or even no triangles so how do
we know how many triangles there are and
how do we solve for those missing sides
and missing angles that's we're going to
talk about in this video so the first
thing you want to do is you want to drop
a perpendicular like this okay and you
want to find out what that altitude is
or what that height is okay and so way
you would do that is you can just use
regular right triangle trigonometry like
you're sohcahtoa and so you would say
all right the sine of 30 degrees okay
let's put that over here so we've got
sine of 30 degrees equals the opposite
side over the hypotenuse so that's H
over 10 now if we cross multiply we get
H equals 10 times the sine of 30 degrees
sine of 30 sine of 30 is 1/2 times 10
gives us 5 so this height over here is 5
okay so you're with me so far
but now here's the thing when you have
this side side angle condition and the
way I've written it like this it's very
descriptive because the lowercase a
indicates to us that this is an acute
angle all right less than 90 degrees and
the side that's adjacent or next to that
acute angle
see how I did a capital letter so that's
longer that represents longer than the
side that's across from okay across from
that acute angle see how this is shorter
the one next to it is longer that's
what's called the side side angle
condition the ambiguous case and so what
we're doing is we're dropping it
perpendicular but what you want to do is
you want to look at the side here the
side six okay and you want to realize
that they didn't tell us anything about
this angle up here at the top so you
could think of this as being on a on a
pivot or on a hinge and it's very
possible that we could rotate this okay
in such a way that you could actually
draw the side six like this
not like that okay so you see me so
basically it's like if you think of this
is on a circle like this okay
all we're doing is we're just rotating
that side so there's actually two
triangles possible so when this side
opposite the acute angles in between the
altitude v and the side adjacent 10 that
tells you that there's two triangles if
this side here was actually shorter than
the altitude like for when you go to
rotate that okay you go to rotate it
like that it's gonna be too short and
won't even be able to reach that that
opposite side there would be no triangle
and then if it was exactly five of
course it would be a right triangle and
if this side here is longer than ten
let's say it was eleven this would the
only way it could swing is out this
direction so you would only have one
triangle possible but this is a special
case where the side opposite okay is in
between the altitude and the side
adjacent and we have two triangles so
what I would do at this point is that I
would actually double down here okay in
a sense I would just split them up okay
so basically what you have is you have
let me switch to markers here for us so
we've got this triangle like this okay
and then we've got this triangle like
this this angle is still 30 this side
still 10 this side still six okay but
what we're gonna do now is we're going
to do the law of sines okay and so we're
gonna say the sine of 30 divided by 6
equals the sine of C we'll call this
angle over here C divided by 10 so let's
go ahead and calculate that so sine of
30 okay over the side opposite six
equals the sine of angle C over its side
opposite 10 so if we multiply both sides
by ten ten times sine of 30 sine 30 is a
half that's gonna be five six so we have
five six and if we do the sine inverse
of five six we get angle C so let's go
to the calculator and let's calculate
that so we can get a better idea and
let's just make sure we're in degrees
okay so we're going to do the sine
inverse of five six which comes out to
56 degree
okay so now you can see this angle here
is going to be the 56 degree one okay
which is right here 56 and what you'll
notice is you see how this is an
isosceles triangle like if this is six
this is also six what do you know about
the base angles of an isosceles triangle
they're congruent right so if this is 56
this must be 56 which means that this
angle here must be 180 minus 56 so
that's going to be 124 so this is 124
now what you can do is you can add these
two angles together and subtract from
180 same thing here add these two angles
together subtract from 180 and then what
you would do is you would do the law of
sines one more time okay using this
angle on this side and this angle here
in this side to solve for that missing
side but the main thing I want